du taxi londonien au bus à impériale
anglais avec l'union jack aux côtés de
la croix bretonne après avoir aménagé
son véhicule christophe et bling a
ouvert sa crêperie le 1er novembre
dernier
coût total de l'investissement 40000
euros nouvelle aventure petit coup de
folie on achète un bus anglais ont la
ménage en crêperie mobile ça peut être
sympa déjà j'aurai un peu plus de place
aux cachets ans les gens peuvent rester
à l'intérieur c'est un peu ma marque de
fabrique c'est la crêperie bretonne avec
des avec des véhicules anglais quoi une
odeur de crêpes plane dans ce bus
anglais les installations d'origine
côtoient les décorations bretonne sur
les écriteaux des conseils pour réaliser
la galette parfaite
on attend que la gale est cuit c'est
simple poisson on s'aperçoit que la
galette et bien cuites
à partir du moment où les bords ont
commencé un peu à se relever
on va faire une complète exotiques
s'appelle la brique poste va bien que le
bus anglais
donc c'est une galette of place du
jambon c'est du bacon un plat salé
mental c'est du cheddar pour
rentabiliser son projet christophe
espère attirer sa cliente est du taxi
pour venir dans son bus et des
entreprises à proximité des clients déjà
au rendez vous trouve ça le concept est
génial de pouvoir déplacer son
restaurant comme ça à sa guise
et puis en plus c'est bon c'est très
sympa c'est très rapide pour nous parce
qu'on a très peu de temps pour manger
donc c'est extrêmement rapides pour nous
on a le temps de se poser on est dans un
cadre différent
ouvert les mercredis et vendredis midi
la crêperie accueille en moyenne 15
personnes ce chiffre atteint la
cinquantaine le week end
un concept qui commence à rouler